un frigo une université était étudiant
comment est ce qu'on peut faire profiter
cet excellent nourriture qui est encore
consommables et ça va être beaucoup
d'étudiants hostiles à passer au travers
des sessions en ayant des fruits et
légumes gratuit les frigos se vident au
fur et à mesure qu'ils se remplissent
c'est valable aussi pour nous de savoir
qu'on redonne à la communauté
universitaire et chimiques
chaque jour et ce même l'été des
étudiants de l'université de sherbrooke
se rendent dans les épiceries de la
ville pour récupérer tous les aliments
des classes et qu'on est venu chercher
des dangers au marché vise dernier des
denrées qui sont des noms se retrouvent
sept gagnants ont les redistribuer à la
communauté étudiants qui on peut aussi
manger plus de fruits les humains nous
aussi aujourd'hui c'est anne catherine
jérémy et catherine qui remplissent la
voiture d'aliments c'est une surprise
chaque jour environ 200 livres qu'on
estime et de nourriture à chaque jour
dont plus de 1000 livres par semaine en
nous on fait seulement du lundi au
vendredi ils prennent la route direction
le campus de l'université
[Musique]
ici marie josée de la co-op alentours
donne elle aussi des aliments de son
épicerie à une autre équipe d'étudiants
bénévoles venus faire le plein on a
voulu voir de quelle façon propre team
is et les produits avec lesquels on
restait prix plutôt que d envoyer au
compostage et on avait entendu parler du
frigo free l'université de sherbrooke on
a fait les démarches puis le partenariat
commencé comme ça launay sur le campus
de l'université de sherbrooke juste
devant le bâtiment eurin donc services
étudiants on a spécialement placer le
frigo là parce que c'est un espace qui
était accessible c'est à côté des
résidences étudiants donc c'est assez
bien situé pour que beaucoup d'étudiants
viennent profiter des denrées
on transporte et dépose tous les
aliments dans le frigo qui seront à la
disposition de tous gratuitement
toujours ouverte et aujourd'hui on est
chanceux aujourd'hui c'est une belle
récolte qu'elles sont très bonnes à
manger très fermes elle semble très
juteuse sentent bon quand tu reviendras
au toucher pendant que le frigo se
remplit sur le campus nous rencontrons
sound est halal l'initiatrice du projet
frigo frigo alors qu'elle travaillait la
corporation de développement économique
communautaire de sherbrooke en place
depuis trois ans il y a maintenant c'est
ce frigo dans la ville on avait tout un
volet éducatif qui nous semblait
vraiment important d'associer à la cause
de la lutte aux ges pillage alimentaire
en a un à l'université on en a au cégep
et on en a deux dans des écoles
secondaires également donc pour nous
c'était une façon d'initier la nouvelle
génération c'est vraiment un terreau
très favorable pour à la fois lutter
contre le gaspillage alimentaire et
inculquer de nouveaux comportements
alimentaires
trois amis du camp de jour et leurs
moniteurs de passage sur le campus en
profite pour faire une pause et prendre
une collation cela
c'est très très beau comme banal non
tant que tel il ya un petit peu non et
si le maître l'autre la manger sucré
paix bonne mais j'ai mis 5 mg une pêche
de bam gros sac de raisin puis je mets
ce prix desana aujourd'hui j'ai pas eu
le temps de dîner puis donc que je passe
par les flics haut et je pense il ya des
filles aux délégués ou pour marge et
aussi nos coûts rapporte à la maison
aujourd'hui j'ai eu la chance de prien
défraîchi gpli aussi dépendre et c'est
quoi le problème avec cette pomme là
vraiment je sais pas je vous montre la
faim partout parfois il a d'elle dans
les fruits et légumes il ya des petits
tournois lots de chasse mais c'est pas
grave on peut les couper puis suivant
anbari le 18 03 2010 9,1 me sens à ce
concert très vite les choses je pense l
emballage qui s'est abîmé
inspirée d'un modèle allemand les frigos
communautaires sont présents dans
plusieurs villes mais la particularité
du projet de la ville de sherbrooke
c'est l'implication de la communauté et
spécialement à l'université et c'est
vraiment un modèle de réussite parce que
le comité frigo le comité étudiant figo
l'arrêt m'en pris en charge ils ont
facilité les choses aux commerçants il
ya évidemment des étudiants qui en ont
besoin qui vient se servir mais en a
beaucoup qui sont sensibles à la cause
du gaspillage alimentaire et qui vient
se servir
par conviction mois le gaspillage
alimentaire ça mais c'est vraiment mon
cheval de bataille quand j'ai su que
qu'une place était à libérer le dans ce
comité là je trouvais que le projet
était tellement beau j'avais vraiment
envie de de contribuer à assurer sa
pérennité
donc je me suis impliqué corps et âme
depuis aujourd'hui et icône rayonnement
sans pareil donc on espère pierre en
effet un modèle qui se multiplient une
vingtaine de villes au québec et au
canada ont demandé à avoir le concept
trois rivières et victoriaville l'on est
planté des demandes vont même jusqu'à
new york
c'est vraiment de voir qu'on a un impact
sur les gens je dis pas qu'ils vont
totalement changé leur consommation mais
c'est vraiment de mettre cette
problématique là de l'avant
malgré le succès de ce projet il y
encore beaucoup à faire
selon madame halal on pourrait
s'inspirer de ce qui se passe en europe
c'est clair que ils sont vraiment en
avance par rapport à nous en termes de
lutte aux ges pillage alimentaire d'une
part obliger tous les commerçants à
donner leurs surplus à des organismes
communautaires et il ya vraiment plein
d'initiatives très possible réaliste et
dont on pourrait s'inspirer au québec et
au canada en général
moi j'aimerais que des frigos et en fait
que le réflexe de jeter n'existait plus
[Musique]